[Music]
[Applause]
ok it's my turn so today we're going to
have vanilla cream pudding sounds
delicious it's vanilla pudding and it's
with Chia I love Chia I love the
consistency and it's healthy right it's
totally healthy Omega mainly 3 but it
has some six high in protein nutrition
and what is what does that do for me
it's going to really make you healthy
well women they need they need the
omega-3 fatty acids women women
especially why well hormonal your helps
them balance their hormones how come
just because ok it's just you know
underneath no basis ah I told you I'd
have to kill you and I don't want to
care again oh I hate those moments
anyway listen when you you make pudding
with chia I found something really
fascinating in some recipes that chia
sits maybe you guys know the answer this
and you can enlighten me but the chia
will set up firm with just a little bit
of chia and other recipes that I do it
requires more chia for a thicker
consistency I don't really care I love
chia so if I have to add a little bit
more to get the consistency I want I'm
all good basically she's saying it
expands and it thickens in a thumbnail
sketch that wasn't what I was saying I
just summarized with you it's some chia
I find does a better job at thickening
than other chia like a chia pet pet
alright
so we show them how to make it know
let's taste it first I did oh how was it
great you like it's really good I didn't
taste it yet you should try it okay mmm
now I sweetened these Chia puddings with
stevia sweetener this one I have a
vanilla cream stevia love it we good
it's really good um I have a chocolate
one that you're going to see chocolate
stevia great you can use plain and you
know but
I love it it's awesome it's awesome
awesome sauce awesome Chia sauce
we're rambling so we're going to we we
mean we we need her
all right let's show how to make it hey
you probably already subscribed but if
you haven't press this little button
down below and I will keep you updated